(Deep-throating) Hrh-Hello everybody
My name is Markiplier
Wade: Markiplier
M a r k i p l i e r
Wade: LET'S SET SAIL LADS!!! (Mark: ...wut?)
I'm almost positive that every single person that's ever played this or made a video has probably
committed to the pirate voice the whole way through
Mark: Should we..
Wade: You're right
Mark: Should we maybe...
Wade: (In deeper voice) We should talk like this instead
Mark: (laughing) What the hell is that?!
Mark: *laughing* What the hell is that?!
Jack: Did you have a stroke?!
(Bob just laughs)
Wade: Let's set sail.
Mark: (in some deep-voice impression) We. Should. Talk. Liek. Thiz.
Mark: Wait - hang on - where am I - there you are-
Mark: (laughs at Jack)
Jack: Oh my GOD
Mark: You're HIDEOUS
Mark: Oh my god...
Wade: But I look good!!!
*music of horror plays*
Mark: Yea, what's up
Bob: We're harmonizing so sweet right now...
Mark: Hell yea we are
Mark: It's almost like... We're in tune...
*clamor*
Jack: O sheet
Jack: I'm about to add another layer
*Mark laughs*
Bob: Oh would you stop fucken' throwin' up on me?!
Wade: Sorreh
!
Bob: Goddamn!
Jack: Are we all gettin drunk immediately?
W: They were all fads
Bob: yes plz
*clamor*
Mark: Uhh guys do you see this skull in the sky?!
Bob: Jack, c'mere, Jack.
Jack: Is that Voldemort? Why is he here?!
Bob: This is rough... This is really rough...
Mark: Welp, I'm puking on Tina. Sorry, Tina :/
Mark: Welp, I'm puking on Tina. Sorry, Tina
Wade: You puked on Tina!
Mark: I'm sorry
Mark: Tina, stop running away from me, Tina...
Jack: SWEET JESUS
Bob: Tina I need you!
Mark: Tina please...
Jack: Come on!
Jack: STOOOP!
Jack: I'm jumping into water to wash this shit off.
Mark: I don't think it works that way
*splatter*
Mark: WHAOAW who puked on me??
Jack: Yea when you play the music while drunk it's all out of tune
Mark: If I play it in the water what happens?
Jack: It goes muffled
*laughing*
Bob: Oh my god
Mark: Ahhh that's nice~
Bob: This is how music works
*Mark laughing*
Bob: This is how all of this works...
*Everyone laughing*
Wade: How we get air underwater?
Bob: Jack just swing around with the - with the Squeeze Box
Mark: Sque-.. Did you call it a Squeeze Box??
*Wade laughing*
Wade: Why you called it a squeeze box?
Bob: I don't know. Isn't that what it's called?
Mark: You went to Music school!
Mark: You call it a Squeeze Box?
Bob: That's not an accordion, if you're.. if you're swinging it..
...supposed to be called an accordion. That's not an accordion.
Jack: It's a melodeon
Jack: Oh blues!
Mark: Oh, Sharon.
Sharon is my kind of woman
Bob: Sharon... Sharon..
*creepy laugh*
Mark: I got a banana
Bob: Alright I'm a banana yanker
Mark: What do I do with all these bananas?!
Jack: Shove'em in your face!
Mark: I'm trying!
Wade: Take up and--
M: Can I shove them in other places?
Cannot store banana in cannonball barrel? This is bullshit.
W: ..Help!!.. Something is wrong with it.
Wade: [inaudible] Where you decided--
J: Oh! wait.. Wait Mark..
M: what are you talking abou- what?
J: Mark where are you?
M: Well I just went to get more bananas. What?
J: Come here. Load yourself into a cannon
M: I don't... that feels like a bad idea. Hang on... okay...
J: It's fine, it's fine. It's fine don't even worry about it.
M: Wait hang on wait.. alright, okay..
Bob: Guys, guys, I have a (inaudible) mustache now
J: Okay.. Are you ready?
M: Yeah, I'm ready. *boom*
AAaaaAHH!!
*everyone laughs*
M: Ah-hey, am I gonna die?!
B: Wait Wade
M: I feel like am gonna die.
J: I donno..
M: I might die! This is gonna--
W: We'll find out
*SLAP*
M: Ow. I'm fine.
He-- He broke my leg. I'm limping back to the boat
J: Wait! Me next, me next, me next!
B: Okay
J: P-Put me somewhere good.
W: God... What are you doing?
M: *laughs* Just the head sticking out.
J: I'm gonna end up in a different game!
W: Oh.. Ohh noo
B: Bye!
W: Why's that a--
J: AwaaaaaaaaaaarrrrrrrrrGGhhhH
W: That sucks
M: Ouhwww..
M: That's that's...
B: What the shit?
M: I think you did toss him into another game
W: How do you, How do you aim this?
M: I'm gonna try to skip you like a stone, okay?
W: Aw, I'm going straight again!?
M: This'll work... *laughs*
M: This'll work, trust me this will work
Wade: I dunno abou--
Weaaarrrgggghhhhhh
Mark: It did not... work..
B: Look it look at my thing
M: Where's your-- how do you pick up a thing?
B: Mark, here, here
M: I'm trying okay?
J: It's okay
B: Hold "E", hold "E" to go to your quest menu, dumdum
Mark: Uuuuhhh *accidental gunshot*
Mark: Whoops sorry, sorry about that
Bob: Ahhoohh!! What da shit fuck! About that
M: Whoa this so cool.
B: Oh my god. This is amazing.
M: Oh, this is so cool. Oh my god
B: Oh my god.
M: Oh my god this is the most.. these are the most beautiful waves I've ever seen in a game!
Bob: Look at this fucking water.
Jack: Great
Mark: Oh my god.
B: This is ridiculous
M: How's my computer rendering this? This is beautiful.
J: It's all on the cloud!
Wade: (inaudible)-- lads!
M: It's on the cloud...
(Bob laughs)
B: I fucking... trying... it's not exactly obvious when we're going straight.
M: I fucgeff-I fell off, I fell off!
(Wade laughs)
Help! Help!
J: Oh my god
M: Help!.. Help!
W: Get on the ladder! Get on the ladder!
Mark: Helllpp!
B: Uhh Deathless Death's Death's Death Canvas
J: He's way behind us!
J: Let's raise sails, raise the sails
M: Hellpp!
M: HEELLLPPP!
B: Mark, where are you?
M: I'm...
..underwater I've been pushed under the water by the boat
J: Are you under the boat?
M: No. I'm behind the boat now
hha-ha-Oh, this is so scary!
J: How do I sail?
M: I don't like this! pFaAAahhhh
W: Try that right one
ahhh ahhh ahhh ahhh!!
M: Oh my God
Jack: W and "S"
Wade: double-u?
B: Okay
M: I look down in the ocean; it's just nothingness,
..it's so scary...
J: Yeah it's fucken tiring --
B: Wait. Where is Mark? I don't see him
M: I keep being pushed under the ocean.
B: Back left alright
J: Ahahah Look at'im *laughs*
J: Put the fuckin' sword away!
M: I?-eh- What do I do? What's gonna make me swim faster? My... My squeeze box?
J: Hold "Shift"
B: Come here you fucko
M: Ooooohhhh! That is something. Oh yeah, that makes sense
(everyone laughs)
M: Nah, you know I'm 'onna play my squeeze box. It'll give me the...
B: Y'know what? Fuck you! I'm turning the lights off
M: NO(x16)
Okay, I'm climbing back on. I'm sorry. I'm sorry
J: Okay.. I feel like
B: *inaudible* rise *laughs*
J: I feel like we need a ship-- a ship basics crash course
W: Alright drop the sails.
M: Don't-- don't go on to the very tippy edge of the front of the boat.
Is that-- is that like rule number one?
B: That's probably a good first rule yeah?
Bob: Is someone on anchor? Is someone one anchor?
W: Yeah, sure
M: Yeah, okay, I'm on anchor I'm up in the crow's nest, though
B: Not yet, not yet
*Jack laughs*
J: You should- you should fly down the ladder
*SNAP*
M: Ow. Uh, I'm down.
J: Okay there you go... That's-- that's not the ladder.
M: *giggles*
J: Wait Mark, fire yourself!
M: I'm trying.I'm-- I'm'na try it. I don't know how but...       B: Guys I got a quest--
*Bob is drowned out by Mark and Jack's screams*
J: I got you! I got-- oh God!
M: Oh, we got a brig!?
W: We DO!
B: Oh hell yeah.
M: Awwh!
J: We can technically all vote for one of us to be locked in there
M: Alright, well, I'm just gonna go ahead and say it. I think Wade should be locked up
'cause he is a-- *others laughing* he is a fucking menace
OHH, I got a SNIPER!--gun!
B: Oh yeah, I want that sniper gun!
J: It has the coolest reticle ever! M: *moans in pleasure*
B: I know, it's like a shattered glass--
M: It's just broken!
J: We.. We need to go southeast.
M: How do you know we need to go southeast?
J: 'Cause when you check the map it shows you where the next...thing is
M: Oh, sO yOu ChEcK tHe MaP?
*nautibh-brup-prfrtrffrr-eumeumeubbeubue*
B: wooow.
J: See, this is why you get locked in the brig in ten minutes.
*Mark giggles*
J: I'll give you some- some mood, Bob.
B: Oh, yes.
M: Ah... Can I ring the bell?
*ding ding* M: Ding ding! Ding ding!
(J: D'ya like it? Do you like my song?
B: I like it a lot.)
*singing and dinging*
(J: Auhahaha! I miss home--)
*Mark giggling* W: And then there's Mark.
*singing and dinging intensifies*
*more singing and dinging* *others laughing*
J: Uugh.. Quick! get those creepvines. I need to make some lubricant.
M: HahahahaHAhahaha
Wade: That's a..
Wade: That's a Sss--
Wade: That's a Sssubna-
Wade: That's a Sssubnautica referen--
J: YEAH!!
M: Why did you have a stroke in the middle of that sentence?
Wa--hahay--de?
*mockingly* THAT's a submrmrnf
B: How do I possibly climb a rope ladder with this huge fucking chest
J: You have-- you have thunder thighs
M: OoOOOhh you put it on your back!
B: Yeeeaaahh.
W: Sounds like musical farts.
*woosh*
J: Mark what are you doing!?
M: I'm sorry!
W: I thought you wouldn't go off the ship again
M: I didn't know I had-- I didn't know-- Sorr-- I keep tryin' to stab-- I f--
I keep forgetting you don't need to press click when you get the item... there we go. I'm good. Music, guys, music.
*ricochet*
M: Lalala.
Jack: La la LA la la. Playing with my friend. *Mark laughs*
M: It's so pretty! Look how fuckin' beautiful that is!
W: Oh, with the sun setting right behind it...
B: Look at that sunsets
M: Oh my god
J: It makes me wanna cry.
B: How do you load a cannon into a cannonball?
J: Then you equip the cannonball?
M: ...what.. did you just say?
J: Ooh, this is a fancy chest!
B: oh, shit yeah. M: Oooooohhh
How do you know it's fancy? W: uohh
Bob & Wade: 'Cause it's got gold on it.
M: ooooOOOOHHOOHOOOO I should have known.
Bob, Wade and Jack: The Marauder's Chest!
M: The Marauder's Chest!
Eh, guys, I knew what it was too...
*laughter*
B (mockingly): The Marauder's Chest-- Uuh, I knew too! It was the Marauder's Chest.
M: Did you know, it's got gold on the edges, guys. Did you see it?
B: --path...ways?
*thunk* M: Oh, I found it--
*jumpscare noise
M: uoAAH! Skeleton!
This one's uuh- uh- this one's a fancy chest too. It's, uh, I think it's a Marauder.
J: OOH, it IS a fancy chest!
J: it's got dragons on it
M: Oohh-- yeah, I know, I told you, I told you...
J: ...Davy Jones on it!
M: It's, uh, dragon hide... dragon chest...
*deflates with a grunt*
M: Chest of Sorrow, that's what it was.
J: Chest of Sorrow!
J: This is worth a lot, but it fills up your boat with water, so to get rid of it
you need to constantly, like, be taking the water out of the boat.
M: I-- I found it, I'll...
make it my responsibility, I guess.
J: Just-- 's gonna be hard to carry
M: (whiny) Why is this chest just... moaning?
*Wade fake-crying*
M: It's just-- just
OOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO
HOOOO
*chest moans*
M: God, shut up chest. Jesus Christ.
Don't worry, I got the anchor.
...all by myself...
W: Good work!
Glad you did it.
M: Thanks, man
W: I was busy looking at clouds
B: Dat one's a skeleton head.
You guys see it? You guys see it??
W: I see it!! Although I kinda just see...
...Grandma's head...
M: *through giggles* What the fuck is wrong with you...
*giggles all around*
W: I'm just tryna do your voice, sorry.
*Mark and Bob mocking Wade*
M: Uh. jusz. seeh. wa. grammaz... hed!
B: Aye just see liek ah granma's head
J: That was so sincere as well; it's like you just stopped being a YouTuber, and just pffffttt---
W: What the f*k is wrong with you?! *Mark laughs*
J: OH, the chest is-- crying...
M: I got it. I got it. I got it
I'm on it. I'm on it. I'm on it
Bucket
J: OH GOD OUR WHOLE BOTTOM IS FULLL OHHH
M: uh-oh that doesn's sound good...
B: We are fucking booking it boys.
M: Whoa, GEEZ, where did this come from!?
J: It's ok, it doesn't-- it doesn't fill up to an unmanageable level.
M: Wow this bucket is BEEFY if that's what it's doing.
J: *laughs* Yeah!
J: Oh god, I need to eat some bananas. I'm gonna die.
M: Oh yeah, me too.
J: Oh I don't have any bananas on me.
Uh-oh.
W: Right here, right here; there's bananas right here.
J: Right here does not help. I can't see names.
M: Right here, in my pants, there's a banana!
W: Were you the one next to me shooting?
M: Quick, hurry
I'm gonna go make sure our ship isn't gonna sink.
B: It's fine, it's fine.
Wait so we can go cash in our quests now right? We have all-- we have all the quests done...
...so we should go back to... somewhere... and do something.
J: Uh-oh..
M: Yeah.
J: Sometimes in the water you gotta be careful cuz sharks'll come and eat your ass.
M: Oh- uh oh.
W: Help...
Why did you just tell me that NOW--
J: Oh god oUR BOAT SANK!! OUR BOAT'S SINKING!!!!
(collectively) NOOOOOOOOO!!!!!!!!
J: OH NO THE FUCKIN' CHEST OF SORROW!!!
M: OH NOOOOOO
B: OHNOHNOWHATDOWEDOWHADDAWEDOO
M: I was too late!
J: Ok Bob go--
W: How do we fix it!?
J: Bob go back to shore and drop your chest.
M: Oh, no. Wait, it's tipping-- Oh God...
J: Ohhhhh geeeeezz
W: GET YOUR BUCKETS OUT
*Mark oh-godding while Bob laughs hysterically*
*blip*
J: Wait, can we even save-- we can save the chests!
Mark: Aaaaahhh... The chests!!
J: We can clear the chests.
W: *groans* M: *grunts* B: Wait, can we save the boat?? Can you-- can you?
M: What is that, a mermaid?!
Is that a mermaid!?
J: No, no, no, that's a siren. That's how you get back to your boat. Don't click it.
M: Oh... I.. I shot it...
J: God damn it fucking Chest of Sorrow!
M: I'm sorry. I was supposed to be watchin' the--
W: Why didn't we think to leaving somebody on the watch?
J: I don't know..
M: I has-- I even said-- I even said I was like "I'll stay on the boat! and make sure we don't drown"
W: Why didn't you?!
M: Cuz I'm stupid. Okay?
J: Did you did you get the last chest Bob?
B: Yeah. There's still like a chicken thing out there or whatever..
J: The chicken coop!
M: Oh, No Wade's chicken coop
Wade: Somebody save it!
Jack: So...
J: What happens now is that I'm gonna go get the boat, then I can bring it back
M: Oh okay.
J: Oh if someone needs to guard the chest in case another ship shows up
W: two go and two stay
M: Alright, I'll stay
B: I'll go, I'm an excellent boat guy.
W: I'll stay, I'll stay
J: So if you guys press Z, you can do emotes
M: Okay
B: Keep yourselves entertained, kids. We'll be back *laughs*
M: I gotta dance!
M: *laughs*
W: [unintelligable] you got there, buddy?
M: Oh my God, I just remembered how ugly I am. Wow
J: What do you really think about the other guys?
B: Well, let me put it this way.
W: Like this?
B: I want the chests, so we have to go back.
J: I don't want the guys, but they're kind of a package deal.
B: Yeah, yeah, we sort of left them in charge of that.
W: Do you sense a dickishness in the force, Mark? I do.
M: *laughs*
M: There's a great dick-turbance in the force
*all laugh*
M: As if a million dicks cried out and then were suddenly silenced.
M: I think I'm emptying the ocean, guys.
*Bob laughs*
W: You see it?
B: Are you emptying the ocean onto the island?
J: Wait, wait, we're requesting back-up
M: And oddly enough, I think it's working. The tide keeps going lower than it was before
M: Wade, am I crazy, or is the water level dropping?
J: *laughs* ...the ocean!
B: Mark, no, you're not emptying the ocean
M: *laughs* guys...
W: No, no, I think he's onto something!
M: I'm onto something
B: Guys, guys, wait, guys. I'm pretty sure-
W: Yeah!
J: You know, y'know whenever we go to conventions and people are like
J: yeah, I think Mark's like the brains of the operation, and then we all laugh and say "no"
W: *laughs*
J: and people don't believe us
J: AAAA we fucking...breach!
B: ooooh we crashed the boat
J: we crashed
J: The ground hit us a lot quicker
M: what- Where are you?
J: We have to take our boards...
W: They're-...come up, come up the hill
J: We're in the island
W: They were definitely in the island
M: Wow. Wow
M: I'm...That's my fault, I was emptying the ocean. I let it go lower than you thought it was. That's my fault
*laughter*
M: All right should we start bringing the chests over?
W: I guess so
B: Yeah, that'd be good
W: I think I'm gonna do the Chest of Sorrows last
M: Yeah, good call, good call
B: I'm gonna raise sails
W: I'm gonna bring them in order of importance
M: If you bring you the chicken coop, god damn, I'm gonna punch you right in the dick
J: Yeah, seriously Wade, we're- I'm voting you in the brig if you're bringing the chicken coop
*Bob and Mark laugh*
M: Oh, God damn it, Wade!
W: *laughs* Come on guys, come on
J: Okay anchor is drooped.
J: Okay
W: Oh yeah, Mark, there's a skeleton there
M: Uh, thank you very fucking much
*Bob laughs*
W: Forgot about that guy as I was running by
*Mark and Bob laugh*
M: Guys you left me on this island with this asshole
*Jack and Wade laugh*
M: You said you were gonna get the chest of sorrow last, you dick.
W: Okay, says the guy trying to drain the ocean by dumping the water on the island
M: I- It was working!!
M: You saw it was working!
B: Oh my God, we're sinking again!
B: We're fucking sinking
M: no no no no no no no no no no no no
M: No we're not (x4)
M: Alright, just get the ship going, I'll be dumping it.
J: okay
B: Alright, I'm gonna full sail this shit. Let's get the fuck outta here
W: Where's my chicken coop?
B: Wade, nobody fucking cares.
W: I don't feel like I'm making any progress with this water
M: No, we're making progress
Jack: Maybe you should have had your chicken coop that probably would have helped right
Wade: Yeah, it would've! I did bring my chicken coop but someone got rid of it, assholes!
Northwest
Ramas you you did not see your chicken coop. I hid it very well. I mean
Weird
Catch some chickens you make damn. I wish we had that chicken coop. It's gonna be like hey
You know there's chicken coops fucking everywhere for free. Yeah, I don't worry about that. Hey, it's so crying
Hey guys. Good news. It stopped crying. We can stop fighting now you guys if you guys press escape and go to
My crew, there's a there's a vote to lock wait in the break
My crew okay, all right all right
No actually I have no idea how we release you from
What song is that
Alright so about the whole
It's nothing from
Wait wait wait, I'm about to sell mama rotters chest sold neat wait. Did you get anything?
Sold well then that's what we all saw it's fine to our dismay we got no money for those look
I think the game's broken oh
Oh, we could vote to release from the Brig Wow where where this thing again?
You happy I don't know all I see is what God
Okay, you're not in the brig anymore. Oh, hey. What's up booty cards for LIF?
Listen I like to think you did that to yourself. Whoa. I got a reputation increase
Hey, we got money from that one. Whoa. I got eight hundred forty four months. Hell. Yeah. Oh wait now
We're getting money for them. So that was the first one. Okay? No. I'm seeing money. It's just delayed absolute zero
Zero coins in my thing I've got zero coins to the fuck yeah, I've got zero coins. Also as well
I have ten seventy three what?
Do we have to split them what the fuck hey hey hey yeah, hey
To the brig
Okay, okay. I'll show you guys. What what I ended up happening with the money, okay?
So you see that you see look uh-huh
I patch
You on you know what good free
Great job. That's what I say. Oh wait
Accommodation unlocked Oh what keeper of a glittering board?
So you do have the glittering hoard?
Wait wait wait guys guys I can explain
Over over there see over there
Okay all right okay is it buried?
Yeah, yeah, just dig all right. Okay? We got it. I bet I can see go on wait a minute wait wait
Where'd he go I'm digging for treasure guys. That's insane. I don't trust you for a second. He's still our boat
Are you drunk again?
All right, I fucking hear that you bitch, No
Hey wait keep digging that treasure Wade you got it
I didn't know we're leaving Wade here quick somebody help me get the anchor back up
I
Still say we should fly towards that big skull like that's gotta be something right it does feel like it would be something
Why don't we go? We'll check it out? I'm steering the ship. I'll steer over there. Let's do it. Oh
The skulls
indicate
skeleton forts that appear throughout the world where players can find challenging
combat and treasure if you see a massive skull shaped cloud on the horizon follow it and it will eventually lead to a skeleton for
These errors are swarming with foes so don't expect to take them all on your own if you wish to succeed
Boys getting boys get them boys, I just tried to do some there we go oh
Fuck in there. Oh we had a lot of incoming fire
Should we go straight. Yeah, we should go for it Anchorage
Did you get bounced left and right I got blasted off the boat use your fucking guns. I'm out of bullets for my gun oh
my god
I'm so fucked. Yeah. Yeah, don't shoot me. I'm dead I am dead. I'm dead I died okay
What is the theory of the Damned you'll end up on Davy Jones's boat
Oh hey, I'm back, I think. Am I? I I don't know all the boats kept the boat is our respawn point
Has sunk boat has sunk
Jack- Fuck I died.
Up. Yup. Ohp.
Geez I can't see shit. I see I see god. It's white pure. White in my eyes
If the ship is still technically like it is it's gone
The doors open oh yeah, we respawn at a
Alright well if it's between the shark or the island I'll take the island I guess get the sails get the sails
Let's fucking do this
There's nothing up here. There's no point. We didn't need to attack this for it. There's nothing here
We needed to attack it to assert dominance
Right right right. I am stuck oh
Shit oh and into it guys wait, what is happening why I love last words that doesn't sound good
No, I can't okay, oh my god, I feel like oh my god
I'm sorry. Okay wait no guys
Oh
You know we don't like babysit in the storm. If it sinks. We don't have any treasure on it doesn't really matter
Waters we didn't make any money captain
Good luck in the brig in the in the ship sinking right now, yeah
Guys
You're lucky. No LoJack boy. Yeah
Yeah, I hope I end up like drowning in the river. Ha ha ha 1 2
1 2 3
Magic trick see all this water, yeah
Yeah, let's try can you vote on each other as well
Yes on everybody so I guess we win mark yeah
Wait are you in here with me
Hey guys yes, it was
Cool to release people from the break
And thousand percent